ici ça sent bon le marié y aller d'une
demi bouteille d'eau de cologne sauter à
votre santé tout le monde l'univers du
dramaturge bertolt brecht prend ses
appartements à plaisir sous la direction
du metteur en scène olivier besson et
spectacle musical un cabaret déjanté qui
réunit plusieurs des grands textes de
l'auteur allemand brèche c'est vraiment
un auteur politique et donc les
thématiques on aborde c'est le rapport
amoureux mais au travers la question de
l'argent de la question du pouvoir
ces scellés rapport de la famille et de
la d re les rapports bourgeois de la
famille
c'est la question de la guerre du
rapport à la guerre c'est l'exploitation
et c'est beaucoup évidemment puisque
c'est le thème fondamental de brecht
c'est l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme
plusieurs scènes articulée autour d'un
fil conducteur grandeur et décadence de
la ville de mahagonny un opéra de
bertold brecht qui raconte la naissance
d'une ville imaginaire
fondée par trois criminels en amérique
c'est quand même un des plus grands
auteurs du 20e siècle et c'est tout le
temps un travail et un plaisir pour les
acteurs de serpents chez cic replonger
c'est quelqu'un qui interroge le monde
le rapport au monde la justice et en
même temps c'est du plaisir c'est un
cabaret s'est passé il ya de l'amusement
sait jamais c'est didactique mais jamais
ennuyeux comédiens et musiciens amateurs
et professionnels se produiront ensemble
un théâtre à ciel ouvert dans le parc du
château de plaisir plus haut à la santé
2 et 2 être jeune et noble qui
aujourd'hui vont appartenir l'un à
l'autre